[Music]  and so also in traffic news we're taking  a live look at the traffic on the north  end of the strip right now ongoing  construction is just really  you know causing a lot of backups on  that street so a reminder all this week  las vegas boulevard between elvis  presley boulevard and sahara will be  down to one lane in each direction from  seven in the morning until two in the  afternoon so if you want to avoid the  traffic and the congestion some options  are paradise or sammy davis junior drive  to access the strip corridor and this  project is the first of seven phases of  work along las vegas boulevard between  sahara and the 215.